et on commence le club par la réforme
des retraites présentées en conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui si l'exécutif
maintient que sa réforme est juste est
nécessaire il se dit ouvert à des
aménagements Jérôme ramier
le Gouvernement présente officiellement
ce lundi sont texte sur les retraites
mais peu surprise à attendre dans un
projet dont on connaît les grandes
lignes cette présentation en conseil des
ministres lance pour l'exécutif un
nouveau temps celui du travail
parlementaire qui peut amener de légères
modifications moi je souhaite que le
gouvernement avec
les parlementaires à l'Assemblée
nationale puis au Sénat puisse
travailler le texte et l'aménager et en
parallèle de ça il y a ce que prévoit
notre Constitution la possibilité
toujours respectée même en temps de
pandémie dans notre pays de manifester
d'exprimer son mécontentement
c'est ça la vie démocratique des
manifestations qui risquent bien de
s'intensifier avec une nouvelle journée
d'action de tous les syndicats prévus
pour le 31 janvier mais la CGT prévient
déjà que le mois de février et les
vacances scolaires seront touchés si le
gouvernement ne recule pas à partir du
moment où le gouvernement s'entête sur
ce qui fait conflit oui il y a
possibilité qui est des journées
d'action pendant les vacances scolaires
qui je crois durant cette période
s'étale sur plusieurs zones côté
parlementaire les oppositions prépare
déjà le combat dans l'hémicycle et côté
France insoumise on s'insurge des
accusations
il est là pour discuter à l'Assemblée
moi j'en ai assez qu'on me dise vous
faites de l'obstruction parce que vous
allez déposer
nous créerons les conditions que ce soit
pas réglé en 15 jours faites-nous
confiance si on a du temps pour discuter
nous on a toujours dit qu'on prendrait
et on fera en sorte que le débat est
Dieu pour que les Français puissent se
mobiliser le texte sera étudié à partir
du 30 janvier en commission avant d'être
débattu à partir du 6 février dans
l'émission de l'Assemblée nationale
et
donc l'exécutif qui
[Musique]
m'entend Gabriel Attal hier matin c'est
du ouvert à des aménagements hier soir
le président de la République c'est
dilué aussi ouvert à des aménagements
par les parlementaires il y a une
ouverture de la part de l'exécutif ou
c'est un discours convenu je sais pas ce
que vous appelez une ouverture mais ils
vont pas arriver au Parlement à
l'Assemblée nationale en disant non non
maintenant faut voter le texte tel qu'il
est c'est évident c'est de bonne guerre
je dirais que de de se montrer ouvert
pour le gouvernement mais le
gouvernement il a le calendrier avec lui
ou si c'est 50 jours qui sont
extrêmement balisés
ce qui va permettre d'ailleurs ce qui va
lui permettre de probablement de mettre
un frein à toutes les tentatives de de
je dirais d'incontinence en amendement
donc voilà c'est c'est de sur le papier
normalement le texte doit passer très
facilement au bout de 50 jours puisque
vous avez la majorité à droite au Sénat
que la droite soif tirer une balle dans
le pied et
plutôt favorable à cette réforme donc je
vois pas comment ça pourrait ne pas ne
pas marcher alors il y aura peut-être
des effectivement des des aménagements
ici ou là notamment sur la pénibilité
puisque c'est là-dessus que ça peut
porter sur le papier ça parait simple
Frédéric oui sur le papier le chemin
parlementaire est relativement balisé
c'est vrai que ça fait partie des
exercices classiques imposés de dire que
tout est ouvert mais il y a aussi c'est
ce que je suis avec attention la
bataille de l'opinion qui est
extrêmement mal engagée beaucoup plus
difficile qu'en 2010 où il y avait une
petite majorité de Français qui disait
parce qu'on ne peut pas baisser les
pensions parce qu'on peut pas augmenter
les cotisations salariales il ne reste
que le chemin de passer de 60 à 62 ans
c'est des vues comme un effort
raisonnable ce n'est pas du tout le
contexte aujourd'hui il y a vraiment un
point de fixation sur ce passage de 62 à
64 ans et ce qui je dirais gâche
globalement le regard des Français sur
la réforme
pourquoi aujourd'hui cet effort il
n'apparaît pas comme raisonnable comme
ça ça a pu l'être par le passé je pense
qu'on se rapproche trop de 65 ans qui
était au début le projet originel du
candidat Macron et qui fait l'objet
vraiment qui faisait l'objet d'un d'un
rejet c'était vraiment une mesure
chiffon rouge ou repoussoir là c'est
vrai que quand on regarde l'adhésion au
passage de 62 à 64 ans et l'adhésion à
la réforme au global les chiffres sont
quasiment confondus il faut Fiducial
pour SUD RADIO on a que 28 % d'adhésion
et l'adhésion recule même après une
mesure faite au lendemain de l'annonce
par la première ministre donc la pâte de
l'opinion est relativement mal engagée
mais c'est vrai aussi que où il y a une
sorte
d'intériorisation pardon des Français
sur lequel le gouvernement ne reculera
pas parce que c'est le quinquennat
réformateur du président Macron qui se
joue on est à 79% la loi passera en été
à 69% en 2019 ça en dit long sur état
des Français mais c'est point d'enquête
que je viens de citer ont été fait avant
la manifestation très réussie de jeudi
dernier donc dans ce cadre là ce qui va
se produire le 31 janvier pour être un
élément fondamental du récit de cette
réforme le gouvernement qui se dit
ouvert à des aménagements mais qui ne
précise pas lesquels on le rappelle
Emmanuel Macron on a déjà fait
d'ailleurs il l'a dit hier soir il est
passé de 65 ans à 64 ans avec une
accélération de la hausse de la durée de
cotisation pour atteindre 43 ans en 2027
alors quel aménagement possible Emmanuel
Macron a déjà lâché sur la retraite
minimale qui a été prévue pour les
entrants dans le nouveau régime ce sera
possible déjà désormais pour tous les
retraités actuels est-ce que ça va être
sur une petite hausse des cotisations
patronales comme la demander le patron
du MoDem François Bayrou ça pourrait
être également sur la trajectoire de
report de l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
c'est notamment une petite musique qui
monte du côté de la majorité de droite
du Sénat là on est à 64 ans en 2030 ça
pourrait être un petit peu plus tard par
exemple 2032 voilà pour et bien couper
l'effort mais une chose est sûre c'est
petit aménagements ne vont pas faire
reculer les opposants à la réforme ne
vont peut-être pas éteindre la
mobilisation car ce que souhaite les
opposants c'est la fin de cette mesure
d'âge finalement la marge de manœuvre
parlementaire elle est assez mince il
faudrait pas vous savez comment en 2007
quand il avait été question de supprimer
les registres spéciaux que la réforme
coûte plus cher que le régime actuel
c'est quand même le problème quoi si
c'est pour faire une réforme qui coûte
plus cher que le ski préexistait c'est
c'est un peu ridicule avec les 44 ans
parce que ça ça grince du côté des
carrières il y en a certains qui sont
obligés de l'histoire 40% des Français
qui sont pas concernés par cette réforme
pour d'une raison ou pour une autre
c'est-à-dire que près de la moitié des
Français ne sont pas concernés par cette
réforme parce que il bénéficie justement
de de de mesure de pénibilité parce
qu'il bénéficient de carrière longue
parce que bon il y a plein de raison
pour lesquelles vous passez entre les
mailles
et en plus vous avez deux
balises qui sont importantes par rapport
à ce qui ce qui existait la première
c'est la décote 67 ans ça n'existait pas
par le passé simple la deuxième chose
c'est effectivement la retraite minimum
à 1200 alors après il y a tout un débat
si c'est 1200 bruts ou net et en fait
c'est net mais surtout le ministre
disent il y a pas une grosse différence
entre le brut et le net puisque il y a
juste la CSG que ne paye pas les
retraités les plus modestes et les mêmes
exactement mais enfin bon c'est pas une
grosse réforme ce que vous savez pas ce
que ce que les Français ne savent pas
c'est que le Président de la République
était en Espagne la semaine dernière les
Espagnols ils sont en train de faire une
réforme pour aller à 67 ans les
Allemands sont à 67 ans je le sais
d'autant plus que j'ai quelqu'un qui est
proche de moi qui est salarié en
Allemagne il faut qu'il attende ses 67
ans pour aller à la retraite pour
prendre sa retraite vous avez la plupart
des pays européens qui sont dans au-delà
de 65 ans et nous on est en train de
faire un charivari pour une réforme qui
est une réforme est en fait pour dire la
vérité c'est une réformète
dans un dans un contexte qui est quand
même incroyable je vous rappelle les
gens mais il se rendent pas compte
l'espérance de vie d'un homme dans les
années 50 c'est combien c'est moins de
60 ans aujourd'hui on est à 80 ans
c'est obligatoire que ça change
est-ce que c'est entendable est-ce que
est-ce que il y a eu un problème de
pédagogie de la part du gouvernement
quand ivre rappelle que 40% des Français
ne sont pas concernés est-ce que ça les
Français ils l'entendent alors il y a
des choses que les Français entendent
c'est très intéressant ce qui vient de
dire déjà la référence à 2007 il y avait
une vraie différence c'est que l'opinion
soutenait massivement Nicolas Sarkozy et
sa volonté de réformer les régimes
spéciaux et là l'opinion voyait une
justice à cette réforme là il y a une
sorte de dissonance entre ce que dit le
gouvernement c'est une réforme juste et
à tour a raison mais c'est comme ça que
c'est perçu c'est perçu comme une
réforme injuste c'est comme ça que c'est
perçu et c'est vrai que cette barrière
62 64 c'est une barrière d'âge
cannibalisme tout le reste les 1200
euros on a fait une enquête pour le JDD
qui montrait une adhésion très forte en
1200 euros qui a pas une différence même
ça beaucoup de gens pensent que brut et
net c'est brut et net comme pour un
salarié avec 20 ou 25% de moins c'est
des choses qui n'ont pas été entendus
c'est vrai que la pédagogie a été très
mal faite c'est vrai que la finalité de
la réforme a beaucoup fluctué on n'était
pas comme dans la réforme de 2010 sur
une logique dès le début qui avait été
martelé par François Fillon et riverds
sauvons le système là on a été sur une
on a un petit peu nouveau Emmanuel
Macron au mois de septembre c'est une
réforme pour trouver des marges de
manœuvre budgétaire c'est pas très
entendable ça maintenant c'est souvent
le système et on entend la petite
musique du corps qui reprit par beaucoup
d'opposants le système ne va pas il y a
beaucoup d'éléments parasites qui nuit
je dirais une bonne pédagogie de cette
réforme alors l'effet Eurovision ce
n'est moi je suis frappé de voir que ça
ne percute pas bien public ça a marché
au moment du vaccin on vous rappelez on
était les derniers en décembre 2020 puis
on est passé premier pays européens
c'est un effet positif là c'est vrai que
la comparaison avec les autres pays
n'est pas en Europe parce qu'il y a
la déception française parce qu'il faut
le dire il y a le totem de la réforme
mitterrandienne de la réforme à 60 ans
on avait fait une enquête à l'époque
avec la Fondation Jean Jaurès pour les
40 ans du 10 mai donc en mai juin 2021
on demandait aux Français spontanément
et en assisté quelle était la réforme la
plus importante des de la décennie
Mitterrand c'était très nettement la
réforme des retraites la même enquête
faite en 2011 pour les 30 ans du 10 mai
c'était l'abolition de la peine de mort
à la cinquième semaine des congés payés
il y a une sorte de de sacralisation de
la retraite en général comme nouvelle
vie et
65 ans c'était vraiment le retour aux
années jusqu'à c'était l'abandon
définitive de la qui mitterrandien
64%, ça rentre dans ce contexte là de
rejet très fort mais c'est vrai que il y
a un temps aussi ou peut-être que
l'opinion notamment les catégories qui
vont pas être touchées notamment les 35
40 ans pourraient écouter pourrait
peut-être percevoir davantage
globalement cette réforme ce qui n'est
pas le cas vous parlez de la popularité
Frédéric est-ce que Elisabeth borne a la
popularité nécessaire pour mener à bien
cette réforme est-ce que c'est une
question de popularité c'est vrai que
c'est un atout nécessaire on se souvient
d'un Alain Juppé déjà très démonétisé en
95 quand la réforme sécurité sociale
retraite était venue sur les sur
l'agenda politique au médiatique c'est
vrai qu'elle est extrêmement touchée
dans le catif objets monte une première
ministre qui est à son plancher qui est
très marqué très comment dire touché par
le côté autoritaire brutal de la réforme
le 49-3 lui est très fortement associé
est-ce que c'est un émetteur audible oui
mais je pense que le gouvernement
intérêt à faire jouer le pluralité des
metteurs Gabriel Attal Bruno Le Maire et
est-ce que le président qui a parlé de
manière peut-être un peu inopinée à
Madrid il y a quelques jours ne devrait
pas se mettre en retrait pour parler si
les choses se gardent s'il y a un
sentiment de désordre dans la rue etc il
y a la popularité d'Elizabeth borne et
puis le ministre qui va la porter c'est
le ministre du Travail Olivier du socle
qui on le voit depuis quelques jours il
a cible de la gauche qui lui reproche
ses revirements ça va être compliqué
pour lui de mener cette bataille
parlementaire
on se souvient de 2010 avec Eric wurt
qui est en plus avait des problèmes
judiciaires je sais pas si vous souvenez
c'était pas simple il était pas revenu
quand même donc Olivier du soft c'est
quelqu'un qui est très déterminé c'est
quelqu'un qui d'abord est techniquement
très au point ils connaissent son sujet
par cœur je crois pas qu'il se laisse se
déstabiliser je le crois pas il a
effectivement une image de fébrilité
dans dans l'apparence mais c'est du
solide quel est son image qu'il a dans
l'opinion Olivier du socle Frédéric
est-ce que vous arrivez à savoir oui
pardon franchement il était très peu
connu des Français avant son arrivée
dans la majorité présidentielle il reste
dans une popularité en construction là
il a payé cash la réforme des retraites
dans le dernier baromètre il faut
Fiducial pour préparer match il a perdu
9 points ce qui est pas souvent le cas
dans ce mais il a aussi gagné le soutien
notamment une plus grande visibilité
dans la majorité présidentielle chez les
retraités chez sympathisants de droite
est-ce que c'est lui est-ce que c'est un
émetteur qui peut porter seul la réforme
je ne pense pas du tout Eric verse c'est
vrai qu'il y avait ses soucis je lui dis
jamais il avait une image de sérieux il
avait accompagné Nicolas Sarkozy pendant
sa campagne il s'était celui aussi qui
incarnait à droite la rigueur notamment
la prise en compte de la question de la
dette qui à l'époque était nettement
plus prégnante on sort de la crise
financière de 2008 on parlait de ruine
possible des épargnants etc on n'est pas
dans ce contexte là je pense que le le
quoi qu'il en coûte à très fortement
balayé cette préoccupation sur la lettre
qui est remontait dans nos
préoccupations dans notre hiérarchie des
préoccupations mais dans des segments
extrêmement spécifiques personnes âgées
sympathisant droite ça ça joue le coin
qu'il en coûte dans le rejet de cette
réforme est-ce que il y a chez les
Français ce truc de vous dire mais on a
mis des milliards pour le quoiqu'il en
coûte pourquoi on met pas 12 milliards
pour les retraites clairement c'est
logique d'opinion qui est fortement
mobilisé par une partie des Français
notamment quand on dit que le système
serait en déficit de 2 4 5 millions de 4
5 milliards pardon on a des verbes
intimes qualitatifs mais on a bien fait
ça pour on a bien sanctuariser toutes
telle ou tel dépense on a bien renflouer
des dettes sur les questions notamment
de la santé c'est vrai qu'on est dans un
contexte où la rigueur budgétaire la
question de la maîtrise des déficits
publics alors même c'est une question
absolument centrale n'est pas dans le
SCOP des Français qui reste absolument
phagocyté parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
retraites mais n'oublions pas
l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat ça reste
quand même un sujet de fixation terrible
chez les Français un dernier mot
là-dessus est-ce que finalement le
gouvernement paye un espèce d'effet
pervers pardon du quoiqu'il en coûte sur
cette réforme des retraites oui c'est
sûr que on a pendant quelques mois on a
eu l'habitude de voir les milliards
valser
différence entre trop de contreparties
quand même c'est quand même ce qu'il
faut dire donc effectivement il y a des
Français pour qui notamment les plus
modestes ça doit déstabiliser un petit
peu de de voir qu'on leur demande
quelques efforts pour quelques milliards
justement alors que les milliards n'ont
pas compté pendant très longtemps et on
parlera évidemment de cette réforme de
retraite demain présentation aujourd'hui
en conseil des ministres l'actualité
politique de ces dernières heures elle
est du côté du Parti socialiste Alex on
va refaire le film avec vous le
psychodrame a éclaté jeudi soir autour
de l'élection du 1er secrétaire du Parti
socialiste et c'est toujours pas fini on
le rappelle après et bien jeudi soir
l'annonce de la réélection d'Olivier
fort à la tête du Parti socialiste une
élection qui a été vivement critiquée
contestée qui a fait l'objet
d'accusation de triche de la part du
camp adverse de son adversaire le maire
de Rouen Nicolas Mayer Rossignol et bien
après cet épisode une commission dite de
récollement être composé des
représentants des différentes parties
c'est réuni ce week-end pour passer au
peigne fin tous les résultats du vote
des militants il est recours qui ont été
déposés dans certaines sections et après
15 heures de travaux cette commission
électorale a validé hier la réélection
de l'évier fort qui l'emporte avec
51,09 % des voix contre
48,91% des voix pour Nicolas Maya
Rossignol c'est-à-dire 500 voix d'écart
sauf que les résultats ils sont pas
acceptés dans le camp adverse qui sont
toujours contestés par le camp de
Nicolas Mayer rossignol qui a publié
hier un communiqué car le problème c'est
que cette commission de recollement à
closer ses travaux avant d'avoir étudié
toutes les voies toutes les fédérations
et donc dans un communiqué les
représentants du maire de Rouen
affirment que la direction sortante du
Parti socialiste soutenu par les
représentants d'Olivier fort a proposé
d'arrêter à cette étude systématique
jusqu'au bout des résultats remonter des
fédérations et des contestations en
échange d'un marchandage global d'un
résultat donnant arbitraire la majorité
à Olivet fort c'est inacceptable aucun
parti démocratique ne peut l'accepter à
la guerre année donc pas terminée autour
de cette réélection à la tête du PS et
elle se poursuit même sur les réseaux
sociaux pierre Jouvet le porte-parole du
PS partisan de Olivier fort à tweeté
hier sur les résultats et le tweet les
militants du PS sont tranchés jeudi 19
janvier accorder leur confiance à
Olivier Faure après des contestations la
commission du Congrès à travailler en
transparence procès-verbaux à l'appui
pendant plus de 15 heures et réponse
cinglantes à ce tweet du sénateur de
Paris David Assouline qui est soutien de
Nicolas Maillard Rossignol c'est une
honte ce que tu oses dire là tu sais
qu'ensemble pendant 15 heures nous avons
étudié 62 fédérations sur 30 103 et que
tu as interrompu brutalement ce travail
pour valider unilatéralement ce résultat
fabriqué sans les représentants des deux
autres textes d'orientation démocratie
crée David assoline sur Twitter et bien
un peu plus tôt dans la journée de
dimanche dimanche matin avant même que
la Commission un est vérifié tous les
votes et les recours et bien Olivier
fort accordait une interview au Journal
du dimanche où il assurait que je cite
le résultat était clair et net aucune
irrégularité n'est tolérable mais
certains fabriquent du doute écrit de la
suspicion pour entacher le résultat les
congrès exacerbes les tensions mais nous
devons dépasser cette guerre fratricide
ajoute Olivier fort une manière de
balayer cette affaire et en tout cas
cette interview avant même et bien le
recontage des voix elle n'a pas plu au
sein du Parti socialiste écoutez la
député socialiste Valérie rabot
également un soutien de Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol à partir en moyenne une
commission ce qu'on appelle une
commission de recollement c'est-à-dire
que il faut un pointage fédération par
Fédération des résultats a priori
manifestement ça prend du temps il faut
que elle puisse aller jusqu'à son terme
et qu'elle soit pas polluée par les
déclarations en disant c'est moi qui ai
gagné le Congrès c'est ahurissant je
suis tombée vraiment je suis tombé de ma
chaise non mais c'est pas digne d'un
premier secrétaire sortant je sais pas
si il sera le premier secrétaire après
cette commission de recommande mais
c'est de toute façon pas digne d'un
premier secrétaire sortant et voilà
c'est Olivier Faure malgré cet épisode
est quand même réélu à la tête du PS et
bien il aura malgré tout du mal à
retrouver l'unité du parti socialiste
merci Alex on va aller à Rouen la ville
de Nicolas mayor Rossignol on retrouve
Thierry habillé bonjour Thierry merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteurs en
chef de Paris Normandie alors Thierry
quel est l'état d'esprit des partisans
de Nicolas Mayer Rossignol déjà ils sont
très fatigués puisque depuis jeudi soir
ils ont très peu dormi puisqu'ils ont
passé beaucoup de temps à justement à
recompter à valider les PV avec les
différents vendant des deux candidats
entre les Mandans de Olivier Faure et de
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol et ensuite
j'irai un triple sentiment stupeur
stupeur car les partisans Nicolas Maya
officiel sont persuadés que on a volé la
victoire à leur champion preuve à la
pluie deuxième sentiment c'est la
désolation l'image que donne aujourd'hui
le Parti socialiste qui sort d'une
présidentielle à
1,7%. on faisait des comparatifs dans
notre éditorial signé ce matin entre
2000 2009 avec la guerre entre Martine
aubry-ségolène royal à l'époque il y a
plus de 200 000 militants en cartés aux
parties socialiste aujourd'hui ils ne
sont plus que 40 000 et à peine à moitié
en participer au vote et le troisième
sentiment c'est la lucidité la lucidité
en disant tous sur les marchés samedi et
dimanche c'était que quel que soit le
vainqueur que ce soit Olivier Faure au
nicolas mayoroscillol Rossignol on est à
55 ans quasiment le parti va devenir un
gouvernable ça va être très compliqué
demain de construire une nouvelle offre
à gauche et notamment avec le Parti
socialiste qui serait le parti qui
pourrait peser demain sur l'horizon 2027
et donc voilà stupeur désolation
lucidité chez militants de Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol à Rouen merci beaucoup merci
Thierry d'avoir été avec nous depuis
Rouen la ville donc de Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol et on suivra bien sûr avec
vous ce qui se passe du côté du Parti
socialiste du côté de roi regarde la Une
de Paris Normandie retraite le bras de
fer ne fait que commencer c'est à la Une
de votre journée ce matin merci beaucoup
Thierry Rabier quelle image ça envoie du
Parti socialiste Frédéric à une image
désastreuse alors quand même nuancon
Oriane la vie des organisations
partisanes n'intéresse guère les
Français on a tous en tête Reims mais la
différence c'est bien sûr et ça a été
très bien dit par Thierry le congrès de
novembre ou des novembre 2008
qui devait sacrer Bertrand Delanoë qui
avait perdu etc Martine Aubry dans le
porte de très peu c'est contesté par les
partisans de saganemariables mais ça
n'avait pas feuilletonné de mémoire dès
lundi mardi suivant c'était fini alors
le PS avait été très affaibli ça avait
annoncé l'échec des européennes de 2009
mais après des grands succès électoraux
là le PS n'est pas dans le même dans le
même état beaucoup moins
d'adhérents dans notre baromètre il faut
Fiducial pour match et SUD RADIO quand
on demande qui incarne le mieux
l'opposition à evanacron moins d'un
Français sur 10 cite le PS à gauche
c'est la France insoumise qui a pris le
lit et c'est vrai que cette opposition
ce 55 ans ou 51 49 en son âge on dirait
qu'il y a une marche d'erreur et c'est
ce que dénonce les partisans Mayer aussi
est-ce qu'on continue ou pas dans cette
nups ou certes ça a permis au PS de
sauver les meubles grandement aux
élections législatives mais ça efface
nationalement le peste parce que pour
les Français à taureau a raison mais
c'est comme ça il y a une sorte
d'équation nups égale LFI elle est fille
égale Mélenchon donc en termes
d'incarnation Olivier Faure peine à
exister en tout cas oui ça donne une
image désastreuse et on a un parti au
bord de l’impression il y a ce congrès
de Marseille dans quelques jours on va
peut-être retrouver une violence aussi
forte que congrès de Rennes au début des
années 90 est-ce qu'on peut voir le PS
disparaître après cet épisode Yves ou
pas
on n'est pas loin du théâtre de
boulevard là c'est c'est
ça me fait penser vous savez où partir
radicale radicale socialiste qui était
le parti phare du début du 20e siècle et
aujourd'hui qui peut se réunir dans une
cabine téléphonique donc
pardon
et donc le Parti socialiste on va voir
je pense que moi je suis je suis
d'accord avec Frédéric je pense que les
Français n'attachent pas beaucoup
d'importance à la vie partisane beaucoup
moins aujourd'hui que par le passé
d'abord parce qu'ils sont moins engagés
les uns et les autres quel que soit leur
famille politique qui soit à droite à
gauche c'est pas parce que le Parti
socialiste était en très mauvaise
posture aujourd'hui que la gauche est
menacée disparition Frédéric Lady à la
France insoumise il y a l'incarnation
est ailleurs aujourd'hui elle n'est plus
dans le PS le PS peut renaître de ses
cendres
il a déjà vécu des alors évidemment
c'était dans des périodes un peu plus
vastes mais il a déjà vécu la guerre
comme ça fratricide il a toujours vécu
de ça d'ailleurs regarde Mitterrand
Fabius Jospin Ségolène Royal Martine
Aubry il y a toujours eu des des bons
il faut qu'il retrouve une incarnation
forte et puis des idées qui peuvent
correspondre à une partie des Français
donc je dirais pas qu'il est 10 qu'il
est en voie de disparition il est dans
une très mauvaise posture mais il peut
renaître à tout moment parce qu'on voit
très bien qu'aussi des partis qui sont
qui paraissent en forme comme la France
insoumise la France insoumise est un
malade qui s'ignore en ce moment quand
même hein
est-ce que dans le rapport de force PS
la France insoumise ça donne un point à
la France insoumise
c'est d'abord c'est elle qui a
l'initiative de cette de ce
rassemblement de la gauche c'est elle
qui a les incarnations les plus fortes
c'est elle qui porte la voie de la
gauche qui s'est du coup radicalisé mais
on l'a vu ces dernières semaines
il y a une telle je dirais une ambiance
pas loin d'être détestable à l'intérieur
de la France insoumise qui fait que les
les les
solidarité n'est pas tellement au
rendez-vous c'est ça le problème oui le
problème c'est toute la gauche d'une
manière d'une manière générale sur
l'incarnation à l'opposition d'Emmanuel
Macron il y a une formation dont on peut
parler depuis ce matin c'est la
rassemblement national c'est une partie
qu'aujourd'hui incarne mieux
l'alternative à Emmanuel Macron d'un
côté il y a une gauche mélenchoniste
tribunicienne qu'ils agitent beaucoup
dans la rue avec peu de succès la
manifestation de samedi de jeunes a été
14 à 15000 personnes sur le cabinet
occurrence c'est très peu pour une
manifestation par rapport au grand
succès de celle de jeudi mais le
rassemblement national qui combat la
réforme des retraites qui n'est pas dans
la rue de plus en plus gagne des des
brevets de respectabilité et c'est vrai
que la différence avec les guerres
fratricides Ops qui va évoquer c'était
qu'on était dans une logique de
bipolarisation gauche droite là le PS
est dans une logique de compétition
interne pour incarner le mieux le visage
de la gauche et le visage de
l'alternance et on suivra évidemment ce
feuilleton qui se poursuit du côté des
socialistes en garde challenge de nos
quotidiens avec Alex
[Musique]